[Music]
the fantastics in mother are a
group of this grandmother we have every
day to photograph and
collect data from the sea snakes which are
venomous
at the beginning we are waiting for them with all fear
but very happy and helped to make
this  participation in scientific research
every day in the morning we get
up we say to ourselves today what are
we going to see
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is monique the sky I am 70 years old
and  i have been retired for ten years the
fantastic grandmother seven in number
there is geneviève briançon maryline
sarocchi
sylvie hébert
cathy lebouteiller
monique won
and then
the group was formed in
2007 we have every day with the aim
of helping the search for  find our
girlfriends to participate in collecting
data that will be useful to clairoix
rang
[Music]
my name is that to see years and it's me
who does the scientific studies
on sailor children I've already been asked
why I work  he was with
grandmothers and why not
grandmothers we could laugh one
grandmothers only know how to make
jam they only know how to make
knitting then we no it's our sport
exactly working with the team  from
grandmother started a little bit by
chance it's at the universidad night baccalaureate
it doesn't get worked nor walsh the
only one to work with volunteers
on big poisonous snakes on
dangerous animals lines up sneakers a
dynamic I knew  for a
long time because diving in the
same diving club it is aline who will
propose to take these photos for me and
who then proposed to her neighbor
to also become a helping hand
they asked another girlfriend for another
girlfriend and without having done it on purpose
I found myself with this team of this
grandmother who do an extraordinary job
they allowed us to know a
lot of things that we would not have
suspected until now
this  day of 9 entation mother it
starts in the morning at 7:45 a.m.
so we take the masks, snorkel fins,
our cameras and we get
into the water
if the sea is very calm and if there is
no current we go as far as
sailing to the rock and back what it takes
us between about two
and a half kilometers of swimming every
day the first time I saw a
snake in the sea
I was actually very scared the air
we  really prepared
to photograph them how to approach them
if we see that they are coming towards
us clearly took us we remain stable we do
not move he does not attack they are very
curious he really lets himself be a
photographer he
the quantity of snakes  listed in the
bay of lemons surprised the researchers
we are at 260.2 before
starting the study I would have bet on
three four maybe 10 maximum we
know that they will necessarily eat a
lot of fish each year so
we  knows that their role in the
function  nment of the ecosystem is
important I am very proud of the work
accomplished by this
grandmother's team it is even an honor to be able to
participate in the search for clear water
to be able to help people it's
fantastic
[Music]